hello is this white with a faster game
coming up on the ship comedian and
awards host Dara O'Brien tells us how
he's guiding the next generation into
gaming fighting for games glory find out
who won what at the ceremony and away
from video games talent we check out the
hot new crowdfunding campaigns making
the most of the weather hello and
welcome to swipe from the batter games
awards 2016 this is the one night of the
year when the biggest names behind video
games get together to honor the industry
Talent and what a massive industry it is
in the UK alone it's worth more than 4
billion pounds now just before the
ceremony I got to catch up with
tonight's host comedian and gamer dhara
O'Brien this is your seventh time
hosting your name is Leonard you keep
coming back it's crabbing Jack I enjoy
and there's an effort of this is very
different to I've host about to tell you
to the wall I thought for any movie
awards and took that kind of fun as a
good to do because a lot of kind of the
hangers arm and kind of the beautiful
people who are just there to be see and
be seen who since seeing who's been
saying this is the people are really
interests but it's their industry and
they were really really hard in these
things and they really want to know who
wins will actually a very much more
investor than this which makes it
actually just a fun gig to do thank you
very much thank you very much good
evening one and all and welcome to the
2016 British Academy games awards you've
got a lot on your plate then haven't you
he represents you've got your hosting
yeah but you're too yeah that got it a
costly I'm going with you gaining big
Amy occurrence very nice very small
periods of time you know cuz it was
slight like that I I claim to be a game
work and I 44 you I don't get
hey maybe we can take ages to do I get
it has a dip a toe in them but most of
my gaming now is now doing my little
ones even so it actually moved on that
I'm basically guiding another generation
into the world of gaming I get a little
lot a little bit of a circle my hairless
but I you know I I don't finish anything
well they play don't know pain but to
fit ya know you do you'd bring it around
with you know troop into those are you
there for one night and then plug ping
them and then set the whole apparatus up
like whatever Dave actually adds a lot
more buddy but who doesn't at this stage
you at this what people was talk about
gaming's if it's kind of this niche
thing who doesn't on their phone or on
their iPad have a load off yeah do you
think there is still a little bit of a
snobbishness from some people who don't
quite get gaming that it is just a hobby
for for younger people yeah there was a
kind of thing I think the average ages
in the thirties never people actually do
this the gender breakdown has gone more
female than male even in the last one
because the things like casual gaming
look when you got the Prime Minister
admits to play fruit ninja this gaming
now means so much stuff that it's
actually quietly and they know this
Stella largest entertainment industry in
the world like it could buy television
it could buy film it doesn't need to
what it doesn't have obviously it
doesn't have the star so it doesn't it
won't get the red card won't be around
the people in frogs on something like
that but you know they're kind of okay
with that now because they know it
doesn't matter cuz they're in everyone's
home so it doesn't really matter that
they won't get the same kind of girl
amorous glossy coverage that their bat
film would for example fantastic to meet
you we know you've got to go to break
your leg prepares grip for that sounds
like I gotta come up with ten these
jokes but games y'all got long I know
like here we go do that
coming up in a bit will be checking out
a smart bottle that makes water out of
air and light that's along with some of
the week's other tech news but first
here at the BAFTAs it's been an eventful
evening there was some clear favorites
going into the show but were there any
surprises here's Chris with a roundup
and the BAFTAs best game goes to fallout
4 post apocalyptic survival game Fallout
4 claimed the top prize at this year's
BAFTA games awards a big game with a big
development budget it's what's known in
the industry as a triple a title but its
creators did have some advice for the
independent companies looking to emulate
their success I look back at the history
of our company Bethesda's only we
started with we started we started many
many years ago was kind of small role
playing games and quite gradually built
the company grew the company and as you
know successful for the way and now
we're you know we're top top 5 publisher
global so i think i think persistence is
the key thing it can keep persisting and
believe in what you're doing leaving
your dreams believe in your vision and
indeed it was a much smaller game that
attracted a lot of the attention going
into the event everybody's gone to the
rapture a british game made by indie
developer the Chinese room was up for
ten awards including best game and best
British game in the end it took home
three prizes for audio achievement
performer and music I'm so proud of the
team I run the Chinese room with my
husband Dan were tiny team amongst the
Giants of the game industry here on low
budget game so I think the industry is
genuinely ready for something different
actually
the British games is a really good year
for independent games as well return
small earth of different stories other
nominations for Best British title
included a prison construction and
management simulator and an interactive
movie style game that sees you solve a
mystery using taped police interviews
but it was an American superhero that
would fly the flag for Brickley of the
way Batman Arkham Knight made by
london-based Rocksteady Studios
sweatshop that prize the BAFTA games
awards show just how far this industry
is car and the UK is now the sixth
largest video games market in the world
but not every developer in this country
is having success earlier this year
Microsoft cancelled the upcoming fantasy
game fable legends and closed the guilt
but based Studios working on it while
Sony followed suit by shutting down
evolution studios in Cheshire which
specialized in racing games and just
last week Activision the team behind the
popular Guitar Hero series announced the
number of UK layoffs while big companies
might be prone to the occasional setback
it's clear that the UK's indie scene
remains strong and with more nominations
on the night than anyone else the team
behind everybody's gone to the rapture a
proof of that Chris Cregan Sky News well
as you saw in Chris's piece there there
was a real mix of contenders hoping to
walk away with the best game award this
year so we thought it was worth taking a
closer look at some of those nominations
with our games expert Lucy James 33 is a
Polish role-playing game where you take
on the role of garel to Rivia who is he
essentially a monster hunter for hire
business and it was incredibly
well-received physically because it's
this huge open world and usually these
tuna games they're filled with a lot of
space but the witcher i mean you would
walk around and you could turn a corner
and it was something to see something
you do someone to talk to and that
person will usually be a really
memorable character and the combat was a
lot of fun because the witches the sort
of mutants and they have half magical
powers so it was kind of in terms of a
fantasy RPG was the best of both of all
worlds really
it's character of gelt sort of people
put themselves into and players and it's
always just going to take a big sort out
and kill a giant Griffin or you know
make potion and there's even some ladies
in there that you can have relationships
with it was a lot of fun and I'm really
glad is getting recognition about the
witcher Mel kicillof I've is probably
one of the best self games I've ever
played there was a lot of stuff going on
with the development and a lot of key
staff members left like right at the end
very messy and I kind of hoped that that
hasn't sort of detracted from what is an
incredible game a lot of people will say
that the lack of third maybe isn't as up
to snuff as the rest of it was but
honestly you will find yourself pouring
hours inside game determined to get that
s rank rating going around Afghanistan
killing as many evil infiltrating spies
as you can it's an incredible game and
it's sort of testament to kajima
productions because it looked like it
had a very long development period and
it came out and it was great but Metal
Gear fans loved it and had a dog on your
team and a horse and a silent sniper it
was honestly a lot of fun
if you'd have told me last year that one
of my favorite games would be a car game
mixed with football I don't know what I
would have told you but that was
certainly the case with rocket League
because it is so much fun so you
basically play a game of football
usually four sides but instead of having
players you have cars and the ball has
handed like augmented gravity it like if
it goes up into the air it hovers a
little bit too long it's nice to sort of
get to grips with but soon you'll find
yourself going on YouTube trying to find
out hints and tricks because there's a
thing you can do where you can you know
like boost forward and then jump at a
certain time and do a flip and it is one
of the fun most fun multiple games I've
ever played it's incredible and I mean
it was free for a long time on
playstation plus it was free for a month
and just it gathered such an incredible
momentum such an incredible community
came out of it and honestly psionics had
such a brilliant job with rocket League
now time for a quick roundup of some of
this week's other tech news take a look
at the bottle that creates water out of
thin air pontus works by capturing
moisture than condensing it into safe
drinking water it uses solar energy the
makers say you can clip it to your
backpack and have it fill up with water
while you're hiking the project's
crowdfunding on IndieGoGo for those days
when there might be a bit too much
moisture in the air here's a way to make
sure you never forget your brolly
umbrella connects to your phone and
sends you alerts when rain is on the way
reminding you to take it out with you
the makers who launched the project on
Kickstarter this week boast its ability
to stay strong in windy weather too
and here's another crowdfunding project
making the most of the weather whatley
is a solar-powered water purification
machine and Power Station the campaign
on IndieGoGo is raising money to take 12
Ghana Nigeria or Sudan to give community
sustainable water electricity and
connectivity and a new app launched that
lets you send money in the same way
you'd send a text message your friends
and family don't even need to be
registered users to receive it Circle
has no cash limit and doesn't charge
fees to move money instantly between the
US and UK well that's it for this week
take a look at Sky News on mobile I've
had ketchup and sky cube all the latest
tech news throughout the week we'll see
you again next time bye-bye